Olá minhas amigas meus amigos como
sempre eu peço para vocês me derem um
feedback sobre o áudio e eu tô usando
agora esse
headset porque eu tenho percebido que o
áudio dele fica bem
claro mas vocês podem dar a sua opinião
tá vocês estão me ouvindo bem boa noite
Carlos Boa noite a todos que forem
entrando Carlos me dê um
feedback se o áudio tá bom para você
tá bem como sempre nós vamos responder
as dúvidas do documento depois eu vou
discutir um artigo com vocês na verdade
não é artigo é a aula que foi proferida
lá no Congresso médicos pela vida sobre
biotecnologia sobre nanorobôs
mas eu preciso que vocês me de o
feedback do áudio tá
bem a primeira pergunta deixa eu dividir
a
tela Dr Alan toxicol intermitente Há
muitos meses tem algum significado mais
amplo na saúde integrativa Se sim qual
bem essa é uma condição que ela é
caracterizada por contrações musculares
e voluntárias no pescoço isso causa dor
causa limitação de movimento dentro da
Saúde integrativa
essa situação pode ter implicações mais
amplas pode estar relacionado a vários
fatores parte emocional de estresse
desequilíbrio postural problemas de
alinhamento da coluna
cervical e até mesmo condições
neurológicas também devemos considerar
que o toxicol intermitente ele pode ser
um sinal de distonia cervical distonia
cervical que é uma condição neurológica
que envolve com contrações
musculares involuntárias no pescoço a
distonia cervical ela pode ser causada
por várias questões como por exemplo
mutações
genéticas uso de certos
medicamentos ou até mesmo por condições
neurológicas então no contexto da Saúde
integrativa o tratamento do toxicol
intermitente pode envolver abordagens
como fisioterapia e quiropraxia também
AC
técnicas de relaxamento muscular E além
disso é importante abordar os fatores
emocionais e de estresse que podem estar
contribuindo para essa condição então
fazer técnica de relaxamento de
meditação yoga
mindfulness qualquer terapia de redução
do stresse está
valendo em alguns casos selecionado você
pode estar utilizando a toxina
botulínica o botox para aliviar o
sintoma da distonia
cervical porém é muito importante você
ter um diagnóstico
preciso e o tratamento tem que ser
personalizado né considerando Obviamente
as necessidades individuais do paciente
Carlos você não me respondeu Você está
me ouvindo
bem então continuando o toxicol
intermitente pode ter um significado
Mais amplo dentro da Visão mais
integrativa funcional
indicando a necessidade de uma abordagem
mais Ampla mais holística Ok
considerando fatores físicos emocionais
e
neurológicos a segunda pergunta o risco
de grávida de 2 A TR meses de gestação
fazer despara é realmente alto Qual
sugestão de quando fazer se é que pode
ser
feito Sen as dicas de alopáticos mais
seguros e ou fitoterápicos e tintura se
puder falar sobre as doses das
tinturas bem tintura eu não recomendo tá
Por quê Porque se tiver qualquer
problema na gravidez a culpa vai ser da
tintura obrigado pelo feedback Carlos eu
acho só tem você ao vivo né Acho que não
entrou mais
ninguém bem vamos falar sobre uso de
antiparasitários durante a gestação no
nos primeiros meses não deve ser
utilizado a não ser em último caso Ok
então no primeiro trimestre da gravidez
que é a parte mais crítica não deve usar
nada
tá o risco da
despara não é necessariamente alto mas
tem que ser avaliado muito
cuidadosamente não se faz no primeiro
trimestre
posterga tratamento para a
terceira o terceiro trimestre né o a
parte final da gestação se possível tá
Ou pelo
menos após as primeiras 14 semanas de
gestação
então você pode fazer no segundo ou no
terceiro
trimestre no mínimo no segundo trimestre
Ok então em caso de complicações graves
da infestação pelo parasita Aí você faz
no primeiro trimestre da gravidez eu
gosto de usar o bendazol
que é uma evolução do mebendazol tá
então eu usaria a o
Albendazol uma única dose de 400
mg mas o mebendazol ainda é aceito como
medicação para tratar
parasitas enquanto com abendazol é uma
dose única de 400 mg o mebendazol é um
comprimido de 500 mg de manhã e à noite
12 em 12 horas por TR dias consecutivos
Boa noite Eliseu Boa noite
Eliane em relação às tinturas já falei
eu não faria de forma alguma tintura do
protocolo da ruda Clark
Porque qualquer coisa que acontece na
gravidez Vai ser culpa da
tintura próxima pergunta Doutor Qual a
ferramenta de a comenda para perguntas
relacionadas à
saúde Olha a melhor ferramenta para
perguntas em geral não só da saúde é
você associar a ia
com a busca como se fosse o Google né a
busca na internet a ferramenta que eu
acho fantástica para isso chama-se
perplexity tá bom
perplexity
ah deixa eu descer um pouquinho mais
aqui alguém colocou data de nascimento
na pergunta aqui acho que foi algum
engano
aqui eu vou digitar aqui
tá E vou colocar na tela aqui para vocês
verem Essa é a ferramenta que eu
recomendo tá e o site do perplexity é
perplexity
pai tá deixa eu ver se eu consigo editar
aqui
é
[Música]
perplexity paii ou ai né em inglês né
esse que é o site isso aqui é fantástico
tá tem um plano gratuito e o pago eu
tenho pago porque ele é muito bom
tá tem uma também ferramenta mais
científica Isso é para artigos
científicos tá que você acessa no
typeset.io
esse aqui se você quer ver parte de
artigo científico tá essa ferramenta
typeset.io na verdade ele vai dar certo
a acesso ao si Space deixa eu dividir a
tela com vocês aqui do
sipace para vocês
verem ó Isso aqui é a tela do sipace
Pera aí será que eu tô
mostrando é do cspace deixa eu ampliar
aqui tá e que vocês vão conseguir
acessar através do
typeset.io tá vendo aqui eu fiz uma
pergunta How does mth RF ou mthfr
deficiency Impact Iron absorption aí ele
vai Pesquisa os principais cinco artigos
sobre esse tema e respondeu aqui tá
vendo isso é uma ferramenta mais
científica Mas se vocês tiverem
interesse também é muito bom tá
sipace é a ferramenta Porém para acessar
é o site
typeset.io tá para poder acessar essa
ferramenta aqui deixa
eu Stop screen vamos apresentar de
novo das
perguntas um conhecido meu de 10 anos
tem tem dificuldade de se concentrar
para ler um livro devido ao TDH por
causa disso ele lê gibis Já percebi que
tem muita energia e disposição para ler
livros mas obstáculo que o atrapalha é a
dificuldade de concentração ontem ele
pegou um livro normal de 400 páginas e
conseguiu o milagre de ler um Capítulo
antes de
dormir através de tratamento funcional
integrativo ele consegue com facilidade
se
concentrar ade é um pouco demais
né ou você acha que ele vai levar muito
tempo não sei não conheço ele como é que
eu vou saber se vai levar muito tempo
para conseguir
isso bem respondendo a tua pergunta aí
provavelmente foi liseu não sei nem quem
fez essa pergunta aqui o tratamento TDH
através de uma abordagem funcional ou
integrativa sim vai ser interessante eu
tenho uma criança que Eu tratei com essa
abordagem para TDH tive um resultado
muito bom vai trazer benefícios
significativos paraa capacidade de
concentração dessa criança mas é
importante que você entenda que os
resultados podem variar o processo
geralmente tem que ter tempo e
persistência Então dentro da Medicina
funcional se considera que TDH é
multifatorial temos que pensar em
deficiência de magnésio deficiência de
zinco pensar nos aspectos nutricionais
nos fatores imunológicos pode ser uma
questão autoimune pode ser uma alergia
alimentar temos que pensar em questões
neurológicas genéticas componentes
inflamatórios
infecciosos a parte intestinal né o eixo
cérebro intestino é muito importante o
contexto também social emocional né
então você juntando tudo isso você vai
poder oferecer uma estratégia
personalizada para melhorar a
concentração e outros sintomas
Então quais são as estratégias não
medicamentosas tem l teanina tem
magnésio tem zinco tem a terapia
cognitivo comportamental né que isso já
é uma
técnica que é feito com psicólogos né o
TCC pode ajudar a desenvolver
habilidades e manejar os
comportamentos treinamento cognitivo com
jogos exercícios que podem melhorar
funções executivas
memória de trabalho controle
inibitório é importante fazer atividade
física regular porque vai aumentar
tensão e a parte executiva de
funcionamento
cerebral criar rotinas consistentes
ambiente organizado vai ajudar
bastante utilizar algumas tecnologias de
forma sábia né aplicativos de
gerenciamento de tempo pode ajudar nessa
organização
diária então é um bom sinal que essa
criança tenha conseguido ler um Capítulo
de um livro de 400
páginas então isso para mim indica que
com as condições adequadas ela vai
conseguir se desenvolver e vai conseguir
aos pouquinhos aumentar o foco por
períodos mais longos e sim a leitura de
gibis é benéfica porque o gibi é de
interesse da criança né E vai ajudar a
aumentar essa capacidade de leitura da
criança e pode ser um passo
intermediário né para ela poder ler
livros
maiores então esse tempo que você pegou
tempo necessário para ver melhorias é
muito variável
Ok geralmente tratamento dedh é um
processo contínuo pode demorar muitos
meses geralmente assim se a gente for
chutar um tempo provavelmente entre 6
meses e um ano para ter algum resultado
é mais considerável Ok mas isso é muito
variável at criança que vai responder
com 30 dias outra com 2 anos
tá importante é ter paciência importante
é
adaptar o tratamento para as
necessidades específicas dessa criança
Ok pode ser uma criança inclusive que tá
com diagnóstico de TDH e pode ser outra
coisa pode ser uma dislexia pode ser um
tea pode ser
uma outra situação que tá sendo
confundido com TDH
Ok próxima
pergunta através tratamento funcional
integrativo Ah não que eu já já li
Existe alguma contraindicação do uso de
kelp e odine para nódulo de tireoide n o
kelp não não tem tá na verdade o que a
sociedade endocrinologia Condena é o uso
do gol porque eles consideram que a dose
de odo é muito grande que vai inflamar
tireoide que pode causar hipo ou
hipertiroidismo eles só recomendam o uso
diodo na fa de lugol antes de uma
cirurgia ou antes de um
procedimento específico para preparar a
pessoa pro procedimento Ok boa
noite que mais tá ao vivo aqui acho que
el eu já cumprimentei Boa noite f
Doutor quanto de
proteína devemos consumir por
dia Depende de 0,8 até 1,5 MG kil essa
que é a faixa se você for extremamente
fisicamente ativa pessoa assim que tá
fazendo musculação para hipertrofia aí
você pode aumentar até para 25 m k tá
então para maioria das pessoas de
0,8 até 1 5 mg kilia Lembrando que 300 g
de carne não é que é 300 g de proteína
não tá vai ser mais ou menos metade do
volume da carne vermelha que vai ser de
proteína Então tem que fazer os ajustes
tem aplicativos muito bom para isso tem
um chama cronometer tá cronometer que é
excelente para fazer planejamento
de alimentação é muito sofisticado esse
aplicativo cronometer tá bom é
cronômetro inglês tá chon
tá Boa noite
Luciana Eliseu Tá quietinho hoje Eliseu
tá doente filho Por que que você não tá
mandando Pergunta
aí bem Tem um artigo que eu queria falar
com você na verdade não é artigo é a
aula que foi
dado no congresso do médicos pela vida
mas é muito polêmico isso aqui muito
muito polêmico
mas eu eu vou apresentar para vocês as
informações e vou apresentar minha visão
sobre isso
tá e
depois nós vamos trocar uma ideia sobre
isso aqui mas antes d deixa eu responder
aqui a dúvida do Eliseu Eliseu agora
tava deprimido aí ele curou já quem
coloca a lupos em remissão através da
vitamina D de dado ainda assim precisa
consumir ldn na
axona Não não precisa se o objetivo da
ldn foi só tratar o lupus não precisaria
não ldn coloca doença autoimune em
remissão mesmo que a pessoa não consuma
D3 não eles são coisas diferentes elu a
vitamina D é importante paraa modulação
do sistema imune não se for para
escolher um dos dois é melhor que a
vitamina D de dados esteja em boas
condições né em bons níveis no sangue
do que você ficar tomando o ldn a
vitamina D tá lá no pé tem idade mínima
para usar ldn Que eu saiba não até
grávida pode usar
tá ldn melhora o aprendizado memória se
essa pessoa tiver problema de
aprendizado memória por inflamação
cerebral sim o ldn vai ajudar agora se
for outra causa pode ser que não ajude
Mas vamos ao artigo pessoal então
esse
artigo gente me deu um branco agora mas
quem deu essa aula foi a dentista
lá que fala muito dessa questão da
nanotecnologia talvez vocês me ajudem a
lembrar o nome dela deixa Abrir o site
aqui do médicos pela vida que eu acho
que eu consigo rapidamente ver isso
aqui acho que vocês podem esperar um
pouquinho porque na verdade
Eles tiraram do ar as aulas gravadas mas
eu acho que eles colocaram de novo eles
estavam ajeitando
lá aqui Terceiro Congresso médicos pela
vida
acessar
e-mail
CPF vamos ver se eu consigo ver o nome
aqui é Juliana varão pessoal eu tinha
esquecido o nome dela Juliana
varão eu vou dar minha posição sobre
isso OK você tem todo direito de não
concordar
comigo bem é um tema muito interessante
mas que pode ser muito mal interpretado
é muito complexo esse tema que é a
biotecnologia a
nanotecnologia Os Robôs moleculares
né então o que que são robôs moleculares
são sistema
compostos de máquinas e computadores em
escala molecular que poderiam realizar
tarefas complexas de forma
automatizada desde o diagnóstico até
entrega de medicamentos a nível celular
então isso tá sendo realmente estudado
tem um artigo muito interessante que
Inclusive a Juliana varão
dividiu certo esse
essa referência desse artigo eu dei uma
lida Nesse artigo mas aí que aí que
morre mora o problema né porque a aula
dela Digamos que 30% da aula foi baseada
Nesse artigo os outros 70% começa a ter
um monte de especulação que o artigo não
fala tá então ela pega o artigo para ter
substanci momento né do que ela tá
falando só que ela só usam o artigo para
fazer isso depois ela começa a especular
demais e fala umas coisas como se fosse
Verdade Absoluta tá então antes da gente
entrar nos detalhes porque é um assunto
complicado vamos entender o básico a
biotecnologia usa sistemas vivos ou
organismos para desenvolver produtos já
a
nanotecnologia é o controle da matéria
em escala nanométrica e que permite
criar materiais ou dispositivos
inovadores então a inspiração pro
desenvolvimento desses robôs vem da
células vivas que já funcionam como
robôs naturais muito sofisticados
obviamente utilizando o DNA como
computador na verdade como se fosse o HD
né o disco
rígido para fornecer instruções e
proteínas como máquinas entre aspas para
executar funções essenciais então um dos
maiores objetivos da ciência moderna é
replicar artificialmente esses processos
naturais em Sistemas robóticos nanorobôs
né então o conceito de robôs moleculares
começou a ganhar forma nos anos 1980 com
a descoberta de
um tipo de ligação molecular que cham de
catenanos tá
catenanos que consiste em anéis
Entrelaçados tá então eles começaram a
fazer Então essas ligações entre
moléculas vivas por esses Anéis
Entrelaçados e começaram a conseguir ter
alguns efeitos de máquina então esses
avanços abriram caminho paraa criação de
outras máquinas
moleculares como nanom Notes e 2016
houve um prêmio Nobel de química que foi
concedido a Pioneiros dessa área e foi
um reconhecimento a importância
crescente dessas máquinas na ciência na
tecnologia Então vamos entender como é
que esses robôs molecular
são construídos pera aí pode escrever o
nome do aplicativo por escrito sobre a
proteína que que você tá falando
desculpa que prote ah aplicativo tá
cronet
cron Não não é da proteína é é do deixa
só confirmar se é o site tá certo aqui
para não mas é cronometer é cronômetro
inglês
esse aplicativo é muito bom mesmo deixa
eu ver se é isso mesmo é isso mesmo é
chronometer It smarter Better track your
diet exercise and Health data é muito
bom tá vamos continuar
aqui então os nono robôs Os Robôs
moleculares eles tem quatro partes
principais o corpo sensores computadores
e então o corpo do robô é encapsulado
por uma barreira muitas vezes são
vesículas lipídicas para separar esse os
componentes aí isso é semelhante à
membranas celulares das células Então
essas
vesículas protegem as máquinas
moleculares internas e controlam a troca
de substâncias com ambiente os sensores
dos Robôs moleculares detectam sinais
externos como mudanças
ou a presença de biomarcadores então
eles podem ser formados por
nanoporos que agem como filtros para
transportar sinais moleculares
específicos através de membranas
lipídicas né então imitando aí os
receptores que TM nas membranas dos das
células esses sensores muitas vezes são
inspirados em proteínas naturais como os
canais iônicos presentes nas células e
podem ser manipulados para abrir e
fechar de acordo com estímulos seja Luz
seja temperatura PH variação osmótica
Gente esse é um assunto muito complexo
tô tentando deixar ele o mais simples
possível
tá a segunda parte essencial do robô é o
computador que realiza cálculos em nível
molecular isso pode ser feito através de
qu sistemas de DNA conhecidos como
computing que utilizam reações químicas
baseadas em DNA para processar
informações então ele imita o
processador de um computador utilizando
no lugar de chips né de silício né de
semicondutores usa o DNA ok muito
sofisticado isso um exemplo disso é a
criação de redes neurais artificiais
baseadas em DNA que podem simular
processos de tomada de decisão então
esses computadores podem ser programados
para detectar padrões e responder de
acordo como aprendendo a identificar
marcadores biológicos Associados à
doença por fim os
atuadores são responsáveis por converter
os sinais recebidos em ações como mover
o robô liberar o medicamento então esses
atuadores podem ser estruturas de DNA
peptídeos que fazem parte de proteínas
ou mesmo proteínas completas que
respondem a estímulos
controlados então novamente computador
sensor
atuador o uso de robôs moleculares está
muito muito no começo pelo menos do na
informação oficial na infância mas os
potenciais São enormes né tanto pro bem
quanto pro mal obviamente né então na
medicina esses robôs poderiam
revolucionar o diagnóstico e tratamento
de várias doenças Então veja vocês
Imaginem um sistema que detecta uma
célula cancerígena e libera uma droga
diretamente nela sem afetar as células
ao redor que estão saudáveis seria
fantástico né esse nível de precisão
absurdo poderia Minimizar tremendamente
os efeitos colaterais de vários
medicamentos e aumentar a eficiência
desses medicamentos boa noite Denise
então aí vamos pra área da especulação
agora eu falei até agora Foi o quê o que
tá no artigo né que ela usou parte desse
artigo para fazer a aula
dela agora vamos pra área da especulação
no meu entendimento pelo menos tá existe
a teoria segundo a Juliana varão de que
Essas tecnologias avançadas estariam
sendo já utilizadas no nosso dia a
introduzidas de maneiras que a gente nem
saberia sem o nosso consentimento ou
conhecimento elas estariam sendo
utilizadas em medicamentos atuais que
estão no mercado em cosméticos alimentos
processados e até em produtos que usamos
no dia a
dia então segundo ela onde estaríamos
mais expostos a essas toxinas né de
nanor robô uma das principais fontes
seriam os medicamentos que usamos
regularmente seja de uso oral seja na
pele tópico seja injetável segundo ela
muitos deles já contém nanotecnologia
Ela mostrou umas fotos de que ela
examinou o conteúdo de anestésico
dentário no microscópio que nem é um
microscópio super potente o microscópio
que se usa para microscopia de Campo
escuro Campo Claro que ela comprou da
nova ciência mas que que ela disse que
consegue ver lá
estruturas
dentro do anestésico seria um nanorobôs
Eu vi as fotos e eu não me convenci com
isso tá eu achei esquisito aquilo
lá bem Cada um tem sua opinião Não tô
criticando a Juliana varão
especificamente estou dizendo que eu não
compro essa ideia dessa maneira como
está sendo vendida
tá então esses elementos também estariam
presentes nos alimentos
industrializados e ou seja poderíamos
estar ingerindo nanopartículas
constantemente Outro ponto de atenção
que ela também colocou é tal das
Chemical trails Chemical trails é uma
dita Teoria da Conspiração digo dita
porque eu não Não Sou torcedor nem
contra nem a favor de que aquela
fumacinha que os aviões soltam né Eh no
ar que faz aquelas nuvenzinhas
liberariam substâncias químicas no ar
que poderiamos estar respirando e que
teria nanotecnologia dentro disso aí OK
então as substâncias que supostamente
teriam
nanotecnologia afetariam tanto solo
quanto a água contaminando tudo que nós
consumimos Ok então os robôs moleculares
estariam supostamente presentes em
medicamentos como é o caso que eu já
citei dos anestésicos
odontológicos e estudos recentes
mostrariam que esses robôs moleculares
encapsular em vesículas
lipídicas estariam sendo inseridos em
anestésico não estudos né Essa estudo
que eu tô falando no sentido da
observações de alguns colegas né da
própria Juliana varão e de outros
colegas que estão fazendo essa análise
com microscópio estão alegando que estão
vendo essas estruturas dentro do
anestésico então esses nanorobôs
alterariam o nosso metabolismo inclusive
interagindo com os parasitas que vivem
no nosso organismo isso poderia provocar
uma série de reações indesejadas
intoxicações
então poderia tá sendo exposto a essa
nanotecnologia avançada entre aspas se
você for no dentista
né e que essa tecnologia poderia
modificar o seu corpo num nível
microscópico certo vamos falar agora
sobre os supostos possíveis efeitos de
de diretos né dessa exposição em nossa
saúde caso estivéssemos em contato
constante com esses elementos o que que
poderia acontecer a nanotecnologia
poderia alterar o nosso metabolismo a
produção de proteínas a nossa
epigenética que que epigenética né que
Gene que tá acordado que Gene que tá
dormindo né então poderia est afetando
a ativação e desativação de genes Além
disso os robôs moleculares
modificando o comportamento de parasitas
e outros microorganismos que poderiam
viver no nosso corpo isso significaria
que estaríamos expostos ao novo tipo de
intoxicação que poderia trazer
consequências como Fadiga Crônica
disfunções neurológicas uma série de
outros problemas que muitas vezes seri
muito difíceis de
diagnosticar aí a Juliana varão propõe
uma solução para
isso haveria maneiras de combater
efeitos prejudiciais uma das soluções
propostas que seriam eficazes seria uso
de ferramentas ditas quânticas né mas
antes falar das quânticas ela também
falou de fator de transferência né fator
de transferência é uso eu acredito nisso
que eu acho bem bacana você deve ter
ouvido falar já do fator de
transferência do for life
né tem na manipulação também seriam
moléculas que poderiam regular o sistema
ajudando o corpo a combater várias
toxinas segunda opção antes dos
quânticos
ozonioterapia né que vocês conhecem que
o Eliseu já fez várias perguntas aqui a
respeito que é nada mais que uma mistura
de oxigênio com O3 né que são três
moléculas de oxigênio e ela
neutralizaria o estress
oxidativo provocado por essas
nano aí
tá protegendo noss sistema nervoso
central suplementação personalizada
seria uma terceira
opção dependendo do nível de exposição a
essas ditas toxinas vitaminas e minerais
poderiam ser essenciais para
desintoxicar o
organismo a quarta estratégia seria
detox de metais pesados e
parasitas muitos esses elementos
estariam no nosso corpo sem que
percebêssemos então limpar o organismo
seria crucial isso aí já acho esquisito
tá não tô vendo muita lógica nisso não
não de tirar metal pesado do corpo se
você tir metal tem que tirar mas o por
que que fazer detox de metal e de
parasita e atirar nanotecnologia não
conseguir se você acreditar que
realmente existe uma nanotecnologia que
tá alterando o parasita do organismo aí
faria sentido mas por que que o metal
pesado
entraria nisso não entendi direito
tá obviamente como sempre adotar uma
dieta saudável melhorar o sono praticar
ex físico isso aí já todo mundo já tá
cansado de saber tá
bom aí vamos pra parte quântica tem
equipamentos de tecnologia quântica que
poderiam ajudar a combater essa
intoxicação Então são dispositivos que
poderiam
emitir ondas né eletromagnéticas que
poderiam inibir ou neutralizar as ondas
eletromagnéticas produzidas pela
nanotecnologia então em certo momento da
palestra a Juliana varão falou que tem
antenas
nesse nessa nanotecnologia que por
exemplo você tomou lá né tomou lá sabe o
que eu tô falando né E que teria
nanotecnologia lá e que umas eh alguma
dessas n tecnologias seriam antena só
que eu não achei no artigo nada falando
de antena tá o artigo que ela usou como
base pra aula dela como eu falei a aula
dela teve uma parte especulativa a parte
do artigo a parte do artigo não dá
eh respaldo para dizer que tem antena na
nanotecnologia atual que a gente tem
hoje em dia OK mas aí ela diz que com
haif com várias tecnologias quânticas
você poderia emitir uma partícula
desculpa uma radiação para
neutralizar essas antenas desse
equipamento Aí ela fala de ferramentas
como rif como rpd que é da nova ciência
potentizer que é da nova ciência o
imorph que acho que também é da mesma
empresa estariam entre as tecnologias
que ela recomenda tá então esses
equipamentos identificariam as
frequências emitidas pelas
nanopartículas e emitiria uma onda
oposta para neutralizar ou destruir
essas toxinas aí
OK gente então é é meio complicado
né como é que teria essa solução tão
pronta assim por uma coisa extremamente
nova né se é que existe isso mesmo né
como é que as pessoas da lá elas vão ter
certeza que estão dando a frequência
correta para inibir a antena do negócio
que Começou agora
né bem terminando esse assunto a
nanotecnologia estaria presente toda
parte os seus impactos na nossa saúde
seriam muito maiores do que nós
imaginamos precisaríamos estar atentos
ao que estamos consumindo e ao que nós
estamos expondo né diariamente Mas se
for verdade essa história não lascou né
porque você não teria como nem se
proteger tá no ar tá na água tá no
Chemical Trail tá tch tchã tá em tudo né
e segundo consta né todo mundo teria que
est fazendo Essas tecnologias quânticas
para inibir essas nanotecnologias
certo que que vocês acham pessoal eu sei
que é muito polêmico deve ter fã da
Juliana varão aqui assistindo a Live ou
que vai assistir o vídeo depois não ten
nada contra Juliana Varão tá pessoal sei
que ela tá ficando famosa aí e tudo eu
observo Essas tecnologias quânticas com
muita atenção mas eu sinceramente acho
que muita coisa aí tá muito incipiente
tá vocês estão me ouvindo ainda porque
ninguém mais falou desde que a Denise se
manifestou há mais de 10 minutos
atrás vocês estão me ouvindo bem eu acho
que eu vou mandar uma mensagem no grupo
tá entrando mensagem nova aqui Doutora
medicina
integrativa tem tratamento para uma
criança pré-diabética tipo um e evitar a
progressão sim se você descobrir a tempo
você pode
evitar a progressão da doença difícil é
descobrir a tempo porque geralmente as
crianças quando são diagnosticadas já o
pâncreas endócrino dela já foi Beleléu
vou ler mais a respeito desse estudo
para perguntar na próxima Live vá láu eh
você quer que eu mande o eu vou mandar o
artigo para vocês
no no grupo tá fazer isso aqui
Cadê o
artigo
[Música]
nanotecnology aqui pronto eu tô
colocando aqui no grupo mas é um artigo
muito técnico tá elu muito
técnico já que ldn naona influencia no
prado de memória Será que o ldn
naona pode ser interessante para uma
criança TDH sim eu usaria
sim principal tratamento mas
usaria não Eliseu não vai nessa não
porque apesar que existe essas
informações aí quando eu fiz aó o l
Ribeiro ele falou né que existia essa
situação aí que o ldn poderia impedir a
replicação do HIV eu não confiaria nisso
tá acho que depende muito mais estudo
você tá falando da nanotecnologia
concordo com você Carlos
em qual estudo Ribeiro se baseia para
dizer que água de coco impede Que HIV
evolua para eu não achei esse artigo
aliz eu eu lembro que ter falado isso
que o ácido láurico do Óleo de coco ou
do água de coco poderia ter efeito
antiviral para HIV mas eu lembro que
quando eu pesquisei isso eu não achei
nada
Ah sim o
quê
eh o o senhor tem indicação de
profissional para indicar pra mãe de
criança
pré-diabética criança aqui em São Paulo
eu os casos de Pediatria Geralmente eu
falo para procurar jeisa Quental tá
jeisa com g de de gato
Quental Como escreve queijo com Q tá
jeisa Quental e l no final
tá Qual é o nome daquele médico
americano que foi a pessoa com diabetes
tipo um que mais viveu não sei Eliseu
ele tem um protocolo para diabetes tipo
um você aprova eu não eu não sei quem é
Eliseu não sei dizer não precisaria dar
uma
olhada Eu acho que vocês não gostaram do
artigo não porque vocês não estão
comentando nada aqui do artigo não né da
aula lá da da Juliana varão que eu
narrei para vocês aí né
eu acho que eles não
gostaram porque só estão fazendo
perguntas de outras coisas aqui ninguém
tá comentando muita
coisa mas é um assunto bem difícil
mesmo vamos encerrar com 45 minutos tá
pessoal tá faltando qu 3 minutos mais ou
menos a gente encerra aqui
gente eu tenho um respeito admiração
muito grande pelo drir Ribeiro mas eu
falo pros pacientes eu
só tiro mais ou menos 80% que eu aprendi
na na na pos 20% das coisas que ele
falou Eu geralmente eu já modifiquei
esse meu pensamento porque eu fui atrás
de outras
fontes Eu acho esse assunto muito
viajado É verdade Luci viagem na
maionese mesmo viaja lascada
mesmo ao comer 200 g de semente de
abóbora a pessoa deve suspender o
suplimento zinco já que essa m de
abóbora é muito rica em zinco depende
depende do de quanto que ela tá com
deficiente de zinco tá isso é individual
cheguei tarde peguei o comentário do
artigo no meio tá bom Denis depois você
assiste o vídeo por
inteiro que pena perdi a Live não perdeu
nada não Pessoal vocês t esse negócio
assim você perdeu ao vivo tudo bem mas o
vídeo vai tá lá né É só assistir o vídeo
novo sem problema TAM miquinha Você
assiste depois lá se você quiser você
faz uma pergunta na próxima Live ao
vivo ou faz a pergunta no no no
documento e a gente responde E você
assiste depois da Live também foi muito
interessante o assunto mas foi de
impacto e necessita ser digerido É
verdade tem que ser digerido mesmo esse
negócio é muito muito louco meu
lembro-me de que o tal médico entrou pro
livro dos records por ser a pessoa com
diabetes tipo um que mais viveu na terra
não sei quem é pode ser que até que ouvi
falar mas já saiu da minha memória eh
depois eu se você achar você me manda
Eliseu no grupo lá
beleza mais um minutinho pra gente
encerrar a
Live alguma outra pergunta
pessoal e Imagina eu já sou acusado nos
vídeos de falar que tudo faz mal se
agora começar a falar no no canal do
YouTube que tem nanotecnologia de nano
robô no ar na água e tudo com até canto
aí que nego pula da janela e se suicida
mesmo porque aí não tem mais chance para
nada né Tá too M lascado
ã mais perguntas 30 segundos para
encerrar
isso Fernanda isso aí que você tá
falando procede né Mas eu prefiro deixar
o benefício da
dúvida uhu tem sinan para todo lado Tá
certo né ai ai tá complicado
né Isso também quem assista sim
viu assista Está
sim a gente tem que tomar muito cuidado
pessoal porque tem muita gente hoje eh
se
promovendo com vários títulos diferentes
aí Ah eu sou integrativo eu sou
funcional Ah eu sou quântico ah eu sou
da terapia neural ah eu sou da sei lá da
biopuntura tem profissional Bom e ruim
em todos os setores da vida humana tá
todos os setores da vida humana fizemos
uma obra aqui no imóvel novo do
consultório que a gente se mudou
pouquíssimo tempo o pedreiro que era bom
para fazer piso fez cagada na hidráulica
o cara empresa do ar condicionado que
devia fazer saber uma coisa bem feita
que é mexer com ar condicionado fez
cagada aí eu arrumei um cara que sabe
tudo de tudo e que arrumou um monte de
coisa aqui entendeu então é não adianta
a gente tem que ser muito criterioso tá
bem pessoal Muito obrigado pela
audiência de vocês nós nos vemos na
semana que vem um abraço grande um beijo
no coração até amanhã até amanhã não até
a próxima Até a próxima semana